though the targaryens had forged the
seven kingdoms in fire and blood they
didn't govern with them
until they did
magel first of his name defined council
as confirmation and disagreement as
treason
three grand maesters tried to avert
disaster
instead of taking their advice
magor took their heads
as a second son and exile maegor was
never meant to rule but no sooner did
maker hear of his brother's death then
he flew valerian to dragonstone and
demanded the crown
only the grand maester dared object that
the throne should pass to his older
brother's firstborn son prince aegon
maegor insisted that the iron throne
should go to the man with the strength
to seize it
and beheaded the grand maester
prince aegon soon took him at his word
he claimed his father's dragon raised a
host of western men and marched on
king's landing while magor was in old
town
far from the capital magor couldn't
rally an army to match aegon's so he
ordered his banis to swarm aegon's
larger army from all sides confusing the
young prince and slowing his advance
beneath the god's eye maego's disparate
forces came together and attacked aegon
as maegor himself swooped down from the
clouds
for the first time since the doom of
valyria dragon fought dragon in the sky
that aegon's dragon was no match for
valerian the dread who was four times
its size
when aegon fell to his death his army
broke and fled
before slaying his own nephew may go
forever after became known as the cruel
though of course not to his face
the next grand maester dared object to
make or taking a third wife when taking
his second wife had ruined his brother's
reign
because megan's first wife was the niece
of the high septon
but mega beheaded the grand maester and
declared war on the faith
he set fire to the riverlands the
westerlands and the reach in a campaign
to root out disloyal lords and sponsored
a more pliant high septon
none of it worked
maego may have returned to the capital
with two thousand skulls of the faith
militant but most of them weren't
soldiers they were simple folk who had
sheltered the outlaw septons or turned
out in droves to hear them denounce the
wicked king
the third grand maester dared to declare
maegor the father of his own heir
but when his second wife miscarried and
maegor saw the monstrous stillbirth
mago beheaded the grand maester for his
insolent adherence to truth
so he had no one to warn him when his
third wife
sensing an advantage declared that his
second wife had been unfaithful and
produced a list of potential fathers of
the misshapen child
not only did maegor execute his second
wife and her father his own hand of the
king
but he also marched on her family's
castle and slaughtered everyone who bore
a drop of her family's blood
but his third wife couldn't give him a
child either desperate to cement his
stolen throne with an hair maego took
three wives at once known as the black
brides because each were women he'd
widowed in his wars
all three women grew full with child in
time
but each gave birth to the same twisted
monstrosities as his second wife
one need not be a maester much less a
grand maester to deduce the common
thread here
though maegor stamped out the fires of
rebellion his cruelty and fear only
scattered more tinder over the realm
until even the smallest ember could set
the realm of light one day the faith
militant emerged from the shadows and
the lord sent to quash it joined it
instead his hand resigned and retired to
his island home
finally house baratheon declared for
maegor's own nephew as the rightful king
the lannisters tyrells and aarons soon
joined
adding more than half the might of
westeros to the prince and his two
dragons which became three when maegor's
niece and involuntary black bride stole
away from the red keep with her dragon
her treason wasn't even the last mega's
own lord admiral sailed the royal fleet
into his nephew's harbour but most
fitting of all
when maegor tried to send ravens to call
his banners he found that his fourth
grand maester had learned from his
predecessors
and fled
magos spent one final night on the iron
throne
he was found in the morning with his
wrists slashed and one of the thrones
blades jutting from his throat
nobody knows if he was one of his queens
or king's guard or one of the thousands
who wanted him dead or even maegor
himself frustrated that his body had
failed his will
whoever the culprit no doubt he died as
all tyrants do believing that history
would vindicate him
it hasn't
history may be written with fire and
blood but histories aren't
as any good adviser could have warned
him
the coin of aries second of his name
had landed on madness
but half the coins of the targaryens had
landed so
yet only ares would be known as the mad
king
thanks in no small part to the defiance
of duskendale
duskendale was the greatest port on
blackwater bay until aegon built king's
landing
as the capital grew richer and more
prosperous
it sucked ships and gold away from
duskendale
to halt its long decline the lord of
duskendale sir dennis darklin petitioned
king aerys for a royal charter that
would allow him to levy his own port
fees and taxes which would obviously be
lower than in king's landing
the hand of the king tywin lannister
refused but knowing of the tension
between the hand and its king sir dennis
invited the king to duskendale to
evaluate his petition himself rather
than deferring to his hand
when tywin admonished the king to refuse
as any sensible adviser would
a petulant and bristling air is instead
accepted
traveling to duskendale with a small
retinue and only one of his kingsguard
as soon as aries stepped within the city
sir dennis seized him killing the
kingsguard and the few others who dared
to defend their kin
ares was hauled to the dungeons to have
his beard pulled and have other petty
cruelties inflicted on his royal person
lord tywin immediately raised an army
and marched on duskendale but the dennis
threatened to kill the king at the first
signs of an assault
if sir dennis hoped to force tywin to
offer terms he didn't know lord tywin
who refused to even parley until sir
dennis released the king and surrendered
the royal army surrounded the city and
the royal navy blockaded it
so dennis had clearly not anticipated
such obstinacy
nor that the king's hand would be in no
rush to save the maddening king
when as lord tywin himself pointed out
the realm had a better option in the
king's much more stable son prince
rhaegar after six months lord tywin's
patience was at an end or at least none
could claim he acted recklessly if he
now stormed the city and sir dennis
killed the king
but the dutiful and honorable sir
barristan the bold volunteered to
infiltrate the city and rescue his king
single-handedly as befit his kingsguard
oath
tywin couldn't refuse such valor
publicly
and so begrudge sir barristan one night
then he would storm the city and put
every man woman and child to the sword
with only his hands
sir barristan climbed the city walls in
the dark of night and snuck through the
city disguised as a beggar evading
patrols and suspicious townspeople
when he reached the walls of the city
keith the dunn fought he scaled those by
hand as well
even dispatching the wall guard before
he could sound an alarm with incredible
bravery and luck sir barristan made his
way to the dungeons and freed his king
then sir barristan's luck ran out
the cry went up through the castle
someone had discovered the king was gone
with horns and trumpets blaring an alarm
sir barristan cut their way to the
stables avenging his slain kingsguard
brother the taking an arrow to his chest
slipping through the castle gate just as
it closed the wounded sir barristan and
aries rode through the rails town racing
for the city walls and beyond the safety
of the royal army
lord tywin's archers raced forward to
clear the walls of defenders
and sir barristan the bold earned
immortality by delivering king aerys to
the waiting if not welcoming arms off
his hand
without his hostage sir dennis
surrendered and begged mercy from the
same king he'd imprisoned
most men would have had none ares had
less
he commanded sir dennis to be executed
along with any man woman or child who
bore his family name and anyone who once
had
as for sir dennis's foreign wife who had
urged his defiance aries commanded that
her tongue and womanly parts be torn out
and she be burned alive
it was his first time passing such a
sentence
it must have given him a taste for it
for the king rescued from duskendale was
not the same king who'd entered it
many men would crack after six months in
a dark cell being mocked prodded and
tweaked aerys had arrived cracked
now he was shattered
for years he would refuse to leave the
red keep
encourage now died by his worried
advisors
since he also refused to allow any
blades near his person even to shave his
beard cut his hair and trim his nails he
began to see enemies in every shadow
who vanished
only when the fires burned
you